okay last question today is from Drazen
Drazen said what would actually happen
if roe v wade were struck down by the
Supreme Court very interesting question
roe v wade is the 70s era Supreme Court
decision which prevented the flat-out
banning of abortion in the United States
now of course we've seen at the state
level different ways to define when life
begins and different requirements that
can be passed around abortion services
to make it really difficult to obtain
abortion services but this it's funny
because this came up for Donald Trump
recently Donald Trump and Mike Pence
were recently in the oval office and one
of their legal advisors was saying to
them listen even if you fought somehow
find a Supreme Court justice who would
vote to repeal roe v wade and the
appeals process gets to that point and
you get a vote to repeal roe v wade a
lot of states are going to pass laws
legalizing abortion at the state level
because the repeal of roe v wade
wouldn't necessarily make abortion
illegal it would just say there's no
federal law which says you can't have a
total ban on abortion services period so
then you would just have a lot of states
pass legalization of abortion laws so I
think that you would begin to see a you
already kind of have a patchwork right
like in Texas and Massachusetts the law
is very different but you would see even
more stratification you would see states
if roe v wade were repealed that believe
in a women woman's right to choose what
is right for her medically between her
and her doctor and family if she wants
family involved they would create much
more protected choice laws whereas you
would see the anti-abortion states do
all sorts of crazy stuff so you would
see a wider gap on abortion laws of
course the best or part of the story
when it comes to Trump and pence was
that Trump completely ridiculed him yeah
Mike you're working so hard to get this
thing overturned and it wouldn't even
eliminate abortions in the country to
begin with yeah that's one of those
there were like three different things
where we are story about how Trump makes
fun of Pence's religiosity and one of
them was after a legal adviser said you
know even if you get roe v wade repealed
you're still going to have some abortion
and Trump said something like I told you
Mike you shouldn't be wasting this bus
my
time on this the other things were
asking people who came from Mike Pence's
office in the White House whether he
made them prey and then the third one
was Trump said like oh he wants to hang
the gays oh yeah when the topic of gay
marriage come up he said something like
don't ask pence he wants to hang them
all or something like that weird White
House we've got anyway that's what you
would see if you had a repeal of roe v
wade you would see major stratification
when it comes to abortion laws in blue
states versus abortion laws in red
states thank you for the questions we've
got a great bonus show for you today
david pakman.com slash membership is one
way to sign up for the bonus show
patreon.com slash david pakman show is
the second way to sign up we'll talk to
you that